tout est parti de l'euro raimondo qui
est le président de l'association des
pizzaïolos qui a proposé il nous envoie
un message groupe et il nous dit bon on
pourra peut-être faire quelque chose
pour les ukrainiens c'est par cela et
puis proposent-ils mois menton sur la
place de menton ben voilà
je vais faire venir des fours et puis
enfin des maria rita on va vendre toutes
ses journées comme ça voire deux joueurs
des pizzas
[Musique]
moins fertiles maria est âgé parc
clients viennent pas juste pour une
sorte de pizza qu'on a parce que ce sera
une formule à 10 euros déjà port du
bonnet c'est plus facile et où il y aura
une margarita une chèvre ou une
sicilienne avec la boisson pour 10 euros
il y aura des associations qui ont
offert des desserts vente de boissons
tout ça des cuisiniers qui vont vendre
des plats cuisinés pareil des desserts
des boissons et à la fin de la journée
voilà en effet les contacts en tentant
chacun fera un chèque directement à
l'association des pizzaïolos est
forcément et qui a reçu de sapporo pour
avoir une traçabilité le but voilà c'est
d'acheter un maximum pour pour les aider
ça va se trouver sur l'avenue du tard
donc la vie on fait tous les événements
du chesnay à savoir les chaînes vers la
brocante par tous les évènements se
passent ici pour des raisons logistiques
plus d'habitude depuis défunt des années
des années et ça va se passer le
dimanche qui arrivera le 20 mars de 11h
à 19h
[Musique]